hey out there welcome welcome welcome in
to another edition of Market takes I
know you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me I want to
say thank you for that I'm your host
Dion rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal before we jump into today's CPI
inflation report I just want to make a
real quick announcement we are
supporting our colleague Evan gerskovich
he has been detained in Russia uh the
hashtag is I stand with Evan if you
don't know now you know uh please if you
haven't look into that check that out do
some research we're spreading the word
trying to get awareness out about our
colleague who has been detained in
Russia so I want to make sure I spoke to
that this morning because that is a lot
bigger than a lot of what we're doing
but of course I know you're here for the
data so we are going to dig into that
listen we are talking about everything
from this morning's consumer price index
report it is moving the markets this
morning and I think could potentially
move the markets going forward I'm going
to tell you just why that is so we're
going to talk about what we saw in that
report of course the expectations coming
in how today's report really aligned
with and some of the differences and
some of the interesting wrinkles within
the report today we're going to talk
about of course the market reaction
we've got a new tool we're going to be
able to show you how markets are
reacting almost in real time we've got
about a 15 minute delay on that but
you'll be able to see the reaction from
this report that came out this morning
at 8 30 to right about now as we're
dropping Market takes here at 10 A.M
eastern time of course we're going to
talk about the current environment
surrounding these reports because of
course we know that this reports CPI and
others don't just come out in a vacuum
and then of course we'll be talking
through what comes next so we're going
to get into all that first off the CPI
report this morning showed headline CPI
or overall CPI rising at a five percent
rate so what you're seeing there on your
screen is the year-over-year change in
the CPI now you see starting in April of
2022 it picks up there that was when
we're seeing that 40-year high inflation
in June the third bar there on your
screen that's 9.1 percent inflation the
highest we've seen since the early 1980s
and then you see that just consistent
move lower over those following months
now what's really interesting about
today's report is the actual month over
month inflationally picked up 0.1
percent and that was actually point zero
zero five percent or sorry
0.05 increase so really close to no
inflation increase overall in the month
um that compared to expectations for it
to fall to 5.1 percent year over year
and that was down from the previous
month when it was six percent you see
there in February and then 6.4 percent
you see there in January so it kind of
precipitous continual Decline and
decrease in the year-over-year pace of
inflation according to the CPI now I
want to contrast that with what we've
seen from core CPI and that's an
important indicator because it strips
out volatile food and energy prices to
give you more of an a look at what the
FED can control and one of the things
that the Federal Reserve watches I in
terms of when they're looking at the
market so want to put up here the CPI
core chart and as you see the the
numbers don't go up as high it remains
around six percent but then we still
have seen since late last year early in
uh since about mid-year in 2022 that
those numbers kind of consistently
coming down until you see that last bar
there CPI core picked up by 5.6 uh last
month that was the first increase we'd
actually seen in the CPI core since
September and actually CPI core was 0.4
month over month so again a bit of a
worrisome Trend here where you see
consistently inflation have been falling
declining declining overall and that
continued but core prices stripping out
again food and energy prices which move
significantly uh taking those out you
see it picked up so again just wanted to
illustrate what we've seen long term in
the differences between that CPI core
report and the overall CPI report CPI is
doing what the FED wants it to do just
come down come down come down decrease
until it gets that two percent Target
core CPI though this month bucking that
Trend a little bit and that's
interesting now why do we talk about
core CPI why does it matter well because
it strips out those volatile pieces and
things that the FED really can't control
fed doesn't have a lot of control over
oil prices the Federal Reserve doesn't
really have a lot of control about food
prices a lot of that's based on
Commodities how they're trading on the
open markets what the FED can control by
raising interest rates is controlling
how people are hiring uh whether they're
giving raises things like that because
when markets get tight businesses can't
borrow they can't afford to you know
increase the size of their business as
much consumers can't afford to you know
really take out those loans against
their homes things like that and so it
slows down the economy and when core
prices rise as they did in March you
start to see that be a little worrisome
for the fed and that's why you know the
FED thinks of core CPI as a better
predictor for the future pace of
inflation and even though we have seen
overall generally the CPI come down we
did see that core pickup this month so
that's my there might be a little bit of
consternation in the markets this
morning getting into the weeds just a
little bit I want to I want to get into
here because I know that's what y'all
like you like when we get a little nerdy
and we talk about the details the
shelter prices were lower than they've
been in about six or seven months you
had a point six percent increase month
over month down from point eight percent
in February all that means is that
here's why that's big I want to read you
a quote directly from the bls's CPI
report this morning quote the shelter
index was the dominant factor in the
monthly increase in the index for all
items less food and energy basically
what that means is that core index that
you saw pick up the biggest piece of
that was shelter now why does that
matter because our real-time data has
shown us that increases in rent are
declining that the pace of rent
inflation and overall housing price
inflation has slowed down the FED has
seen this they've talked about it
they've said we know those are coming
down that is a lagging indicator in the
CPI report and the fed and other
economists have talked about well CPI is
most of the thing that's holding
inflation up and it's most of the thing
that's holding core prices up that's
going to go away as the new data starts
to get factored in we don't know when
that'll happen because CPI or I'm sorry
BLS does not have an exact methodology
for when they include changes in shelter
prices we know most people sign a new
lease in January and then they stay
where they are and that's how it happens
but
it doesn't get factored into the data
immediately and so that's a piece that
as soon as that shelter piece starts
stops Rising as fast and that's what it
appears that we're seeing once that
starts happening inflation overall could
start to drop pretty dramatically and
pretty significantly that would turn the
fed from this very aggressive stance
that it's taken to maybe more of a
hands-off stance on the market and
that's a good thing for the overall pace
of the economy on the other side you
know we've always got on the one hand on
the other hand now one big part of the
decline that we've seen in overall the
energy component or the energy index
Fall by 3.5 percent overall and you saw
gasoline the gasoline index down 4.6
from the previous month that's just
month over month after Rising for the
prior two months overall year over year
gasoline was down 17.2 percent well we
contrast that with what we've seen from
oil prices and want to put something up
here on your screen really quickly to
show you boom you see oh overall now in
2022 you see as inflation was Rising as
CPI was Rising you see those gas prices
rising right and then the the same theme
that you saw with CPI going down down
consistently you're seeing oil prices
there on your screen as we get into 2023
now as you get to where we are right now
in April you're seeing oil prices start
to pick back up now that could mean that
you start to see some of these indexes
within CPI pick back up as oil prices go
back up that also has a big impact on
consumer sentiment and how folks feel
about inflation their inflation
expectations so that charge is really
illustrating the overall trend how oil
and inflation have really moved in
lockstep and we are starting to see oil
prices start to pick back up again we're
also seeing this at the pump uh just
when you go to fill up your gas tank we
have seen the average price for a gallon
of gas rise to 362 a gallon up from
about 332 in December so we're seeing a
consistent pickup in gas prices out in
California seeing about five dollars a
gallon almost on gas prices this is a
sort of worrisome Trend that's working
in the opposite of what the FED wants
and we could see we saw that gas price
cut or that oil oil output cut announced
by OPEC the organization of the
petroleum exporting countries they
announced their cutting Supply we know
when Supply declines demand stays the
same prices go up so keep your eye on
that oil prices are going to be
important to watch
um want to put something new up here on
your screen here and that's going to
show you what's happening live in the
markets right now so as we look out here
on wsj.com
you see the Dow the NASDAQ the s p all
Rising higher but each one especially
the NASDAQ coming down and you're seeing
prices start to kind of pick back up but
this is a bit of the tug of war that
you're seeing in the markets want to
throw up here really quickly show you
what's happening with bonds you see the
10-year note uh it's down in yield by
about 3.3 percent or 3.3 basis points
excuse me to about 3.4 percent the
biggest move that we saw in the in the
market after the release of this report
was in the three year and the two-year
you've seen the two-year that that is
kind of come back from that big decline
that it took after the report but
Market's basically telling you with this
that they see the FED having to do less
rate hikes maybe doing some rate Cuts
we've seen that in the FED funds Futures
Market uh the market really saying this
report indicates the FED can pump the
brakes on pumping the brakes slap stop
cutting rates or stop raising rates as
much and the market is even pricing in
some rate cuts through the end of this
year the market expects the FED to raise
rates once in May and then cut them
three times after that very interesting
from the market really quickly want to
show you what we're seeing from crude
oil now this is also important because
when we see Brent crude and when we see
WTI Crude boom you're seeing a big pick
up there you can see this just right
after the report is released jump higher
in oil prices that's because they're
expecting more growth the FED to have to
do less and you're seeing that response
almost immediately from oil prices so
this really the Market's illustrating
what we're seeing in terms of Market
reaction and how investors are reading
this CPI report that we got out this
morning very interesting what we're
seeing there
um let's talk about right now step back
for a quick second and talk about the
current environment what we've seen
coming into this report there has been a
lot less talk about inflation folks are
just kind of assuming hey inflation's
going to come down it's going to keep
doing what it's been doing this report
offered some some evidence that that is
happening inflation is clearly coming
down the fed's processes are working but
there are still some things to keep your
eyes on and we've seen a lot less worry
about inflation recently
um there was however a
something somewhat of a monkey wrench in
that thesis we have seen just yesterday
the New York fed survey of households
showed that households are projecting
one year ahead inflation to be 4.7
percent that is an increase from 4.2
percent in February the first increase
in year ahead inflation expectations
since October so a big part of inflation
is what people expect to happen people
expect inflation to fall so they don't
demand higher prices or they don't
demand higher wages they don't demand a
big raise they don't demand to be paid
more because they don't see prices
rising on everything around them
inflation expectations also tell people
oh well this thing is priced higher I'm
not gonna buy it and I'm not going to
pay that higher price I'd rather just
not pay not buy this item or buy a lower
price item that also helps bring
inflation down so inflation expectations
for the year ahead Rising for the first
time since October last month in the
feds in the New York feds survey of
households three-year inflation
expectations also picked up and but five
years inflation expectations decreased a
little bit to two and a half percent
much close to the fed's two percent
Target the FED has to be a little
concerned about the results of that
survey yesterday because you know that
is something that has a big effect on
inflation expectations and fed's got to
manage those one other note from that
fed survey Americans said that access to
credit was at its toughest level in
nearly a decade that's definitely
something to keep your eye on small
businesses and consumers are having a
tough time getting access to credits
banks are pulling back on lending
pulling back on on granting credit we've
seen that in a lot of the data and that
has just been reinforced by this New
York fed survey BlackRock Pimco and some
others are starting to warn more
seriously about recession risks and that
ties to this lending and this credit a
lot of folks have kind of run out of
money those savings that they built up
during the pandemic have sort of run dry
and now they're doing using credit cards
personal loans things like that small
businesses are having to draw on credit
lines and we're seeing access to that is
getting a lot harder to to come by and
that is generally a good precursor for
recession so definitely keep your eye on
that check out those BlackRock and those
Pimco reports about recession risks they
say that they expect the Federal Reserve
to keep interest rates High even as
inflation starts to kind of come down
even with what we've seen today on CPI
and that could lead to a likely
recession that's what some of those
professional asset managers are talking
about fed speakers over the past couple
weeks have really studied this they've
said we are likely to raise rates in May
uh keep your eye on that fed president
or sorry fed president Loretta Mester as
well as St Louis fed president uh
Bullard both railed in and came in and
said this we expect to keep rates high
so that may just be for May that's how
the markets are assuming they're saying
hey fed's going to raise rates in May
then they're going to cut that's a big
part of the market narrative and the
increases in stock prices that we've
seen lately we're seeing a kind of theme
of the markets versus the fed the
Market's not believing the fed's going
to do what they say they're going to do
keep your eye on that that's a big theme
moving forward listen here's what comes
next we get the PPI report the producer
price index that's on Thursday that's
expected to fall to 4.4 percent we've
seen PPI lead CPI and so if PPI comes in
as expected that's a good sign
especially given the lower than expected
CPI report we got today a good sign that
inflation is moderating going away
that's more good news keep that keep
that on your radar we also get retail
sales the retail sales report is out
Friday it's going to show us what people
are what people are buying what they're
not Bank earnings is out on Friday Bank
earnings are out I should say the big
boy City Wells Fargo JPMorgan Chase
they'll all be reporting on Friday we're
going to learn a lot about the economy
from that and so we will be here on
Monday talking about what we learned
from the bank earnings reports and
everything we got last week and we'll be
looking ahead to next week I hope you'll
join us on Market takes on Monday I will
be talking about the nahb housing market
index as well as housing starts the
fed's beige book and U.S manufacturing
and services ppis we will be getting
into all of the that listen that's going
to do it for us here on Market takes I'm
your host Dion rabone reporter at the
Wall Street Journal thank you so much
for being with us and we will see you
next time